einen der polizisten einen der helden
vom kreisverkehr bild bereits vor
einiger zeit einmal begleitet was kannst
du uns über diesen beamten sagen es hat
natürlich wie sie eben von sagte um
casting bonack 53 jahre alt großer
kräftiger mann kantiges gesicht man
sieht es ja auch in den fast schon die
chronischen video was durch die
netzwerke läuft auch bei uns hat kraft
seiner autorität und seinen banken hin
ohne dass ein irgendwie über zusätzliche
mittel verfügte versucht den sturm auf
den reichstag zu verhindern
er hat schon vor drei jahren hat mein
kollege axel die reporter axel wir ihnen
porträtieren dürfen er ist eigentlich in
ein kriminalitätsschwerpunkt in berlin
am kottbusser tor tätig hat dort täglich
mit drogendealern mit drogensüchtigen
mit kleinen und großen kriminalität mit
arabischen clans zu tun also einen mann
der sich im kiez auskennt und der
wirklich eine harte polizeischule
durchlebt hat in den 30 jahren die einen
dienstes